welcome to the vile villager the show
where we create the biggest POS
character we can possibly make in Animal
Crossing Jake I took the liberty of
progressing some of the the timeline
here as you can tell he ain't no he
ain't wearing no shoes so better for
some change what do you get like 40
bells not much Jake in this episode what
are we trying to do two things we're
gonna start our own Museum because bile
doesn't like the owl
blathers so we'll dig up the fossils and
find out and find a spot for our own
Museum and then we're gonna cut down
these cherry blossom trees because I
think they look a little too nice
I hello one address file up sold badly
something so disgusting you can take off
his shirt and then he's got the white
feeder underneath run inside or just
stand there
just bring it now I was think about this
earlier I was two months earlier Biol
oh yeah I've AK he's an anti-vaxxer dude
totally take he doesn't take no [ __ ]
medicine oh hi there I guess you didn't
see you there my name is bio welcome to
the new
hey Antonio it's Renee you see beyal
outside cutting down every blossom tree
damnit okay you're slow as hell Antonio
[Laughter]
should I make more pitfall seeds or
should I try and just try to get him
with this one or maybe make a lot and
surround him with a parade of just keep
fishing just keep fishing house house
arrest enjoy the fishing stick it's got
a lock the door here might make a run
for it
you know if we get enough animals on
this town and then like build little
cages for them we can pretty much just
become the tiger king yeah let's just
become the tiger king okay that's an
awesome idea sorry Antonio
oh we found it we found his head well
he's wearing on his perfect like his
hair sticking out on the sides did the
gods just give us a gift so appropriate
oh my god hey
Tonia's life now locked oh come on wait
Antonio can you just get into frame
Antonio please stay right here all right
thank you
no Dan these filters aren't working out
it's okay stay right here right here
this is really good this is looking
really good look at the camera Otoniel
wait wait oh my god all right geez one
more one more one more one more in silly
face silly face silly face there perfect
all right well I think we should call it
there right I'd say so we didn't build a
museum but that's okay that's okay we
didn't build a museum we'll do that next
time that's gonna do it thank you guys
so much for watching thank you Jake and
Tony we'll see you another time keep
fishing Antonio we'll talk to you soon
it's back to it
[Music]
you
[Music]